[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire
je reçois dans cette émission le
sociologue jean louis cyr ou pour un
livre tout à fait minutieux sur le
traitement médiatique des gilet jaune
qu'ils se servent de leurs armes c'est
le titre inspiré de la déclaration du
philosophe luc ferry invitant à l'époque
à la radio les pouvoirs publics à faire
tirer sur les manifestants
mais commençons par une image celle que
notre invité est choisie pour illustrer
ce début de xxième siècle jean louis cyr
ou que représente-t-elle exactement
alors vous a commencé parce que je me
suis un peu approprié votre demande je
suis pas certain que la photo symbolise
les peuples dans ces généralités mais à
défaut de symboliser l'époque il sent
qu'elle dit quelque chose en tout cas de
l'état du champ médiatique en plus de
rappeler peut-être quelques souvenirs
aux téléspectateurs français je suis
belge en août et y revenir mais aux
téléspectateurs français qui ont suivi
de près le mouvement des gilets jaunes
alors de quoi est ce qu'il s'agit
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on voit sur
cette image c'est une photo qui a été
prise à namur donc en belgique et on
voit un onguent bord un gros plan qui a
été taguée donc le 11 novembre dernier
le jour de l'armistice et quelques mois
de cela et à tort ou à raison il ya eu
un débat autour de sage mais je vais pas
rentrer dans ce détail il n'est pas
important pour ce qui nous concerne ici
ce cette action a été très attribué
aussi les jeunes belges et sur ce
monument donc on peut lire un slogan
rouge guerre à la guerre il ya un autre
sur le banc derrière et qui allait dans
le même esprit et on peut voir on voit à
gauche le symbole de l'anarchie
on ne voit pas à droite parce qu'il est
caché le parvis lachaise mais il ya le
symbole du pacifisme alors pourquoi est
ce que cette photo m'a intéressé c'est
pas tellement pour l'action en elle-même
il arrivera les choses en dira enfin moi
je n'ai pas un particulier a commenté là
dessus mais vous en doutez c'est plus
par rapport au traitement médiatique qui
a été fait de cette action de ces tags à
savoir que
ça a fait les grands titres des lavoirs
de la presse écrite et qui la journée
c'était vraiment présenté comme une
affaire très importante
le journal de l'est de la télévision
publique en belgique donc l'équivalent
de france 2 a ouvert par cette action
est à déplorer vraiment à condamner
moralement cette action en disant voilà
l'équipe du mans certains ne respectent
rien et cetera et cetera et on a entendu
toute la journée le bourg baisse de la
ville province de namur qui a traité les
jaunes qui était attribué cette action
de vérité le connard le site
donc oui ça a tourné plus ou moins en
boucle toute la journée
donc il ya la fois eu beaucoup de
virulence dans le commentaire
et puis surtout ce qui va peut-être
encore plus intéressé c'est qu'il ya eu
un relatif unanimisme tout le monde
était d'accord pour dire d'une part que
c'est important qui va quand même pas de
soi et d'autre part que c'est très très
grave et très problématique
alors entre autres choses
cette anecdote qu'il sent qu'elle pose
question quant à la possibilité de faire
entendre une interprétation qui sont un
petit peu dit seulement qui sont un
petit peu discordante dans les médias
dont on vante pourtant le pluralisme
très régulièrement
alors qu'est ce que ça pourrait que
cette interprétation ça pourrait être
par exemple simplement vous allez voir
c'est pas trés c'est pas très radicale 1
une interprétation qui tempère ray un
peu l'importance de ce qui s'est passé
là il ya deux tags qui sont effacées le
jour même ou le lendemain je ne sais
plus bon et qu'ils sont pacifiques je
veux dire c'est pas un truc on n'est pas
en train d'appeler à la guerre ou au
contraire donc c'est l'europe aurait dû
se dire c'est on est pour ou contre mais
ce n'est pas extrêmement gras ce qui est
en train de se passer c'est pas obligé
d'ouvrir le journal télévisé par là ou
bien mais on pourra voir une
interprétation qui défendrait ce qui
s'est passé en me disant oui le
pacifisme l'antimilitarisme sa canne des
courants qui ont eu leur heure de gloire
leurs lettres de noblesse et après tout
dans un champ médiatique pluraliste ce
serait pas complètement absurde qui est
moins une deux trois voies qui défendent
ce genre de choses
donc voilà ça fait le lien là évidemment
la question du pluralisme intéressé dans
le bouquin est donc il me semblait que
c'était à la fois une bonne introduction
vers le bouquin d'une piqûre de rappel
quant au fait que
le pluralisme est un combat ce n'était
pas quelque chose de gagner et c'était
pas évident ça pose aussi la question
mais je pourrais peut-être y revenir
plus tard j'ai pas faire trop détaillée
mais ça pose aussi la question des
modalités par lesquelles il est possible
de faire entendre des voix dissonante
dans les médias parce que c'est pas tout
de pouvoir dire quelque chose
l'enjeu c'est aussi d'être entendu
d'être écouté et d'être entendus et les
bandages pourrait vous donner encore
quelques informations sur cette histoire
parce qu'il ya derrière un débat
télévisé au tour et c'est pas la peine
de développer
cette affaire tout de suite ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'effectivement ça ne
touche pas seulement comme on va le voir
les jets les jaunes c'est sur d'autres
sujets aussi il ya effectivement cet
unanimisme de façade qui s'imposent dans
les médias mais mais commençons
[Musique]
jean lui si vous vous êtes donc
sociologue vous êtes l'auteur de la
fabrication des élites qui était paru
chez l'harmattan et vous publiez à
présent qu'ils se servent de leurs armes
aux éditions du croquant une étude
détaillée de la couverture médiatique du
mouvement des gilet jaune qui commence
par la fameuse déclaration du philosophe
luc ferry ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale sur radio classique en janvier
2019 qu'ils se servent de leurs armes
une bonne fois avait-il dit ces espèces
de salopards d'extrême droite ou
d'extrême gauche ou des quartiers qui
viennent taper du policier ça suffit et
il avait ajouté
on a je crois la quatrième armée du
monde elle est capable de mettre fin à
ces saloperies
il faut dire les choses comme elles sont
c'est pour comprendre en fait l'origine
d'une telle déclaration de guerre et la
tolérance des médias à l'égard de celui
qui s'y est libre et que votre livre est
particulièrement intéressant car il ne
s'agit pas d'un d'un pamphlet mais d'une
étude sociologique aux politiques de
tout ce qui a pu être dit sur les jets
les jaunes au cours de la période 2018
vous ne dénoncez pas vous ne prenez pas
partie vous analysez au fond la
rhétorique des commentateurs c'est déjà
du travail d'historien non d'historien
très court terme haussière mais en tout
cas ça me fait plaisir que vous
présentiez livre en disant qu'il n'est
pas un pamphlet car je ne crois pas
effectivement qu'ils sont un parfait
même si a volontairement un peu incisif
un peu
voilà peut-être le titre un peu
provocateur mais par exemple on commence
par là pour revenir sur les déclarations
de luc ferry moi le but
alors je suis bien évidemment comprenant
ce titre là je vous fais tellement je
concentre un peu l'attention sur la
figure et sur la déclaration de luc
ferry mais le but n'était pas d'en faire
un ton noir
les buts étaient pas de m'acharner sur
luc ferry dès lors je pourrais pas très
long très long temps de luc ferry dans
le livre et si c'est la déclaration est
elle tout est une sorte de dérapage
comme on dit parfois aussi c'était
quelqu'un à un moment qu un peu pété les
plombs il n'était pas très en forme ce
jour là et puis le lendemain il revient
sur son pied contre moi je sais pas du
tout ce qui m'a pris je pense pas du
tout de ça ou si c'était juste quelqu'un
d'un qu'une excité et serein je sais pas
moi sur un blog d'extrême droite qui dit
il disait ça je crois pas que j'en
aurais fait le type de mon ouvrage c'est
vrai n'était pas la peine de s'y
attarder
ici ce qui est intéressant c'est que
cette déclaration d'une part elle
provient quelqu'un qui est très légitime
on a quand même affaire un ancien
ministre de l'éducation un philosophe
qui a son rond de serviette un peu
partout dans les médias et il ya une
certaine reconnaissance en tant que
philosophe il nous semble en france et
par ailleurs je veux dire cette c'est
une déclaration qui n'est pas unique en
son genre ce que j'essaye de montrer
dans tous les livres c'est que beaucoup
de voix ont fait entendre quelque chose
d'assez similaire à ce qu'elle dit luc
ferry c'est la légitimité de la chose
dans les cités je crois le mot
légitimité c'est qu'effectivement je
crois que si ce n'a pas suscité plus
d'indignation dans les grands médias si
luc ferry alain qui lui être invités
comme auparavant
et s'il ne s'est pas senti oui c'est un
peu justifiée mais enfin il s'est pas
sentie obligée de faire vraiment une
vérification très concluante on peut
voir en discuter aussi je crois que
c'est parce que voilà certains imaginent
qu'il a eu que des félicitations
lendemain mais il n'a pas apporté un tel
tabou ultime en disant ça c'est quelque
chose qui sont tombés sous une forme
sans doute un peu plus modérée et un peu
moins grossière par ailleurs déjà ce qui
est très intéressant dans le mouvement
des défilés jaune c'est qu'aucun
événement politique n'ait suscité autant
de temps d'antenne et et de commentaires
ça s'étale sur plusieurs mois
rien à voir avec mai 68 en mai 68
d'abord cette dure qu'à moi et puis on
sait qu'apple quasiment absent de la
télévision d'état à l'époque on en parle
très peu
on n'en fait pas des débats voilà là il
ya des débats il ya des gens qui on
parle pendant des mois et des mois pour
un sociologue comme vous c'est un corpus
extraordinaire oui c'est un port plus
extraordinaires et qui du coup présente
la difficulté savoir qu'est-ce qu'on en
fait c'est comme vous dites mais je n'ai
pas tout vu pas polluer malheur 20 ils
devront délit j'avais tout et on voit
jamais tout mais je suis très loin
d'avoir tout vu et tout lui est donc il
a fallu c'est ce que j'explique au début
du livre il a fallu faire un choix soit
que d'essayer de faire une analyse ça
pour être de la lexie comme et rita ça
pourrait être une analyse sur détaillée
d'un petit corpus soit 2 d'essayer de
présenter plutôt une sorte de
présentation générale fin des side cars
étaient plutôt un air du temps vous
dites que ce qui revient très vite et
pendant très longtemps c'est la question
de la légitimité du mouvement
et voilà c'est s'est constamment remise
en cause
la question de la légitimité lé centre
alger la pression dans le traitement
médiatique des gilets jaunes mais aussi
chez les gérer jaune ah oui mais c'est
une question toute façon centrale dans
tous les mouvements sociale et j'ai
envie de dire dans la vie politique en
général parce que la légitimité si
jamais quelque chose qui valent soit
enfin dire c'est être différent entre le
discours politique et le discours
sociologique et les deux ont leur raison
d'être
mais dire x et légitimes y ne l'est pas
c'est un discours politique et c'est
bien le gros des politiques de dire je
défende x et je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire et aida le discours
sociologique il va plutôt s'intéresser à
ce qu'on pourrait appeler les procès de
légitimation les processus de
légitimation et de dire le voilà il ya
une lutte permanente pour définir ce qui
légitime et ce qui ne l'est pas
et donc là dans calais des gilet jaune
mais c'est clair qu'il ya eu il ya une
lutins effectivement un terrain de la
lenteur du gilet jaune comme vous l'avez
dit pour savoir qu'est ce qui est ce
qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on fait pas
puisqu'il est qu'est ce qui légitime de
faire ou pas faire d'aller à la télé en
tant que porte-parole ba de se présenter
à des élections européennes ou pas et
c'est bien d'avoir été les types de
revendications et l'autre et puis il ya
eu un combat symbolique il ya en son
temps un combat discursif c'est ça qui
moi m'a intéressé entre on va dire
notamment déjà entre le pouvoir en place
et ceux qui le contestent pour dire qui
a la légitimité et notamment qui
légitimité de parler du peuple parce que
c'est quelque chose de très important en
démocratie 1c qui a la légitimité
s'exprimer au nom du peuple puisque de
la démocratie alors au moins
formellement c'est le pouvoir qui
appartient au peuple demos discuter les
faits bon la chose est loin d'être
évidente mais encadré discours pour se
légitimer c'est quelque chose
d'absolument fondamentale des viandes
écoutez moi je suis légitime que je
m'exprime au nom du peuple
donc le gouvernement on va dire et ceux
qui le soutiennent vont dire qu'ils
s'expriment du peuple étant donné qu'il
a été élu au suffrage universel et qui
donc il représente le peuple et gilet
jaune vont dire qu'ils ont une autre
forme de légitimité qui est celle par
exemple des formules d'intérêt général
ou de dire ben on vous dit que vous
représentez le peuple mais en réalité
elle représentait pas vraiment car
l'assemblée nationale
morphologiquement elle ne représente pas
le peuple en fait il pas tout y'a pas
d'ouvriers il ya pas d'employés dans
cette assemblée donc c'est en fait une
petite élite
donc c'est plus complexe que ça mais
c'est pour dire qu'il ya une lutte
permanente ont fait un permanent tant
fait pour définir ce qui est légitime
mais les ce qui n'allait pas et le
vraiment ce que ne fera jamais associés
va pas sans l'autre
qu'est ce que je ferais jamais cessé de
dire ça c'est légitime en soi il ça va
de soi ça ne va jamais de soi et dans le
livre phare a d'ailleurs c'est un peu
vous avez vu je pense c'est un peu un
mail et/ou ticks de rappeler qu'en fait
en politique rien ne va jamais de soi en
fait celle de la politique c'est la
contractualité et c'est le coincer le 10
ans us et en particulier la démocratie
donc voilà rien de versoix
or il ya énormément de 2,2 discours
médiatique précisément qui présente les
choses comme allant de soi qui dit qui
présente par exemple comme allant de soi
le fait que va être considérés comme
violents tels actes pendant les
manifestes dans les manifestations alors
que les appels est considéré comme
violent je ne sais pas tu es les autres
telle mesure politique par exemple la
destruction du code du travail ou côté
les types de violence au contraire elle
va pas de vue et c'est donc on est en
permanence dans des luttes de légitimité
alors ce qu'on voit bien c'est qu'en
fait passer un petit moment où il ya une
certaine bienveillance
à la télévision dans les commentaires
sur le mouvement d'elie gilet jaune tant
qu'ils restent sur les ronds points
en fait là il ya quelque chose de bien
vu il ya une bienveillance on voit ça
comme folklorique et sympathique et
d'ailleurs il ya un grand soutien
populaire à ce moment là en faveur des
gilets jaunes et puis dès l'instant où
ils vont commencer à arriver à paris
notamment et sur les champs elysées là
ça change et et en dépit du fait que le
soutien populaire lui reste très
important d'ailleurs mais donc va se
mettre en place une rhétorique à partir
de ce moment là justement sur la
légitimité de ce mouvement alors à
savoir
il n'est pas légitime parce que c'est la
souveraineté populaire ne s'exerce que
dans les urnes et donc des gens qui
s'empare de la rue ne sont pas légitimes
elles faire et puis va y avoir toute la
vérité à partie moment on va voir une
violence s'installer entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre et
se répéter chaque week-end il va y avoir
la question de la légitimité de la
violence la violence seule la violence
de l'êta au fond est légitime dans une
république comme la nôtre
oui il ya beaucoup d'espoir dans votre
du coup je peux la prendre beaucoup de
goût différent peut-être commencer par
dire que vous avez tout à fait raison de
souligner qu'il ya d'abord une certaine
bienveillance mais a été courte dans le
temps c'est vraiment les premiers jours
où les premières semaines mais je veux
dire dès début décembre c'est fini enfin
fini dans la presse régionale peut-être
pas mais je connais moins à la presse
régionale a pour le coup c'est je suis
moins familier en étant pas français et
que cet aspect là mais dans la presse
nationale c'est très minoritaire après
la répression elle n'est pas un tout
homogène j'en suis bien conscient mais
la tonalité dominante après il était
très critique
effectivement on dit du ce qui plaisait
c'était le fait d'avoir alors que yahvé
de la condescendance parfois et puis ça
en est quand même un petit peu les gens
ces blocages sur la route etc
dans les médias c'était pas si bien vu
que ça mais enfin c'était un peu
débonnaire il y était vu comme un
repenti taxis dont qui pourrait être
facilement récupéré par tous ceux qui
sont plutôt de droite ou plutôt libéraux
est local éric brunelle je citais
absolument formidable lui unis lui
trouve ça formidable ville c'est
catastrophique
donc ils essayent donc on voit que les
gens de ne plus aller manifester enfin
il change d'avis comme de chemise
blanche mais aussi alors pas simplement
parce que parce que ce serait les
girouettes mais aussi parce que comme
vous l'avez dit le mouvement évolué et
le mouvement se radicalise en fait ce
qui est d'ailleurs parfois présenté dans
les médias comme un émiettement en fait
des revendications et moi je crois que
c'est plutôt un approfondissement des
revendications c'est-à-dire au départ
puis les gens sont dans la rue il ya une
colère comme unifie peu à peu cette
colère va elle se structure
elle se concentre sur certaines
revendications plutôt que sur d'autres
et il a effectivement le ton va changer
à partir du moment où il ya
effectivement les les premières même
failli premiers dégâts il est les
premiers échanges robail appareils dans
les manifestations qui sont très
spectaculaires d'ailleurs il faut le
dire
là il ya le ton change complètement et
il ya en particulier sur les chaînes
d'information continue même pas
seulement une cristallisation sur la
violence des manifestants est alors
pendant quoi un mois et demi peut-être
un déni en tout cas un une dissimulation
alors peut-être dissimulation gillet pas
d'intention nécessairement mais ils
disent ils ils achètent absolument
stupéfiante et je sais même pas quel
terme employer pour être un peu de
justesse en le disant mais des violences
policières qui atteignent des
proportions rarement vu j'avais dire d
épargne mandela il faut se référer au
travail de david dufresne ce journaliste
indépendant à la qui vient de d'être
relativement ça va être consacré par son
documentaire en documentaire important
et qui a fait un travail indispensable
de recensement des blessés et sans
lequel on aurait on aurait peine que ces
informations mais pour moi ça reste une
question ouverte
étant donné que ce n'est pas fait de
détails graphiques dans les rédactions
et choix piano vous l'avez peut-être
mieux placé que moi pour répondre à
cette question je pense mais c'est de
savoir qu'est ce qui s'est passé pendant
un mois et demi dans les rédactions qui
s'est dit qu'en circuit les partout sur
les réseaux sociaux préférés de se fier
on va dire qu'il est partout des images
absolument stupéfiante
deux blessures de guerre de self et que
rien n'a été dit là dessus
donc voilà qui j'aurais aimé jeu
j'aimerais voir lire ou voir quelle
était l'ambiance dans les conférences de
presse à ce moment là pendant les
considérer la part dont les conseils de
rédaction du tout et ce qu'est ce qui
revient en permanence à cette époque là
c'est qu'il s'agit d'une foule haineuse
7 est un mot qui revient très souvent
dans les médias à ce moment là une foule
haineuse et c'est parce qu'elle est et
haineuse qu'elle est capable de de
violence de destruction mais mais qui
prétend plus parler au nom du peuple et
à qui on répond au fond dans les médias
mais attendez vous des pas le peuple
on est tous le peuple c'est ça ils
serviront à ce qu'on disait il ya
quelques instants sur la vraiment la
centralité dans mc12 en matière de
légitimation de se rendre afin de
pouvoir se revendiquer comme parfum
peut-être pas comme porte parole mais en
tout cas qu'en parlant au nom du peuple
alors il ya effectivement eu pas mal
enfin toute une partie dans le livre
j'essaye de décortiquer ces arguments
qui consiste à diriger les jeunes ne
venez pas le peuple
alors il ya des arguments un peu plus
tôt quantitatif en disant fonder une
fraction du peuple c'est quoi ces gens
qui prétendent parler au peuple alors
que le peuple c'est vous c'est moi c'est
tout le monde dit je ne sais plus qui
conservera le cayrol je suis plus
exactement là nos mémoires mais le chaos
ne parle pas du peuple alors c'est
intéressant parce qu'on peut revenir sur
le raisonnement sur la légitimité à
partir de quand est-ce qu'on est un
peuple devra d'abord qu'est-ce que c'est
le peuple
enfin j à la pâte soit le peuple c'est
un concept mais c'est un concept qui
part qui pas clair c'est pas qu'il pas
clair qu'il est pas bon billet publié
une fois c'est pas facile de dire ce que
c'est le peuple est d'ailleurs pendant
tout mouvement de gilet jaune on a vu
toute une série d'intellectuels elle
veut dire à la télé pour mirabel vous
savez le peuple c'est ceci j'ai ma
définition compost et ça il sait pas ça
et puis d'autres celles y est c'est
palix et je suis pas ironique en 10 ans
et la stella ces différentes définitions
elle pouvait être argumenté les se
soutenaient mais on voit bien internes
en jeu
à deux buts pour savoir ce que c'est le
peuple et une fois qu'on sait entre
vitré est ce que celle peuvent en tout
cas qu'on soit d'accord sur une
définition commune
il faut savoir qu'ils veulent
représenter alors est ce que je sais pas
ça raisonnement que vous avez notamment
frédéric lordon dans un ses bouquins et
qui me sens très très juste à partir de
quand est ce que vous êtes
quantitativement représentatif de la
communauté politique il ya ce qu'il faut
10 % de la communauté dans la rue est-ce
qu'il faut 30% de la communauté dans la
rue et ce qu'il faut 80 % de la
communauté dans la rue en fait y'a pas
de réponses objectives ah ça oui si vous
êtes 100% alors vous voyez vous faites
le pas pour tout le monde mais ne
m'arrivera jamais par définition donc on
voit bien que c'est un enjeu de lutte de
dire voilà on aimer le peuple et le
peuple s'est pas uniquement pour des
actions quantitative et évidemment il ya
d'autres arguments qui peuvent être
évoqués et puis il ya une autre
un autre mode de disqualification pour
défendre le fait que les gilets jaunes
ne sont pas le peuple celui là il est
plus qualitatif c'est à dire à me dire
vous savez c'est peut-être le peuple
mais ce peuple puisqu'il y compte pour
paraphraser un journaliste célèbre est
donc là on arrive dans tout tout l'enjeu
du mépris de classe qui a été très
virulent pendant pendant cette période
je comprends bien en vous lisant et ça
revient à un autre de mes invités récent
l'historien à luc marie qui a publié la
france en colère et qui fait un
recensement de toutes les insurrections
populaires depuis
depuis l'ancien régime d'après lui la
france en serait championne du monde
mais on voit bien et votre livre est
dans la continuité que sous l'ancien
régime
c'étaient les paysans qui se révoltaient
c'était déjà une fraction du peuple au
fond mais c'est une fraction très
importante puisque les paysans après à
l'époque représentait la presque
totalité de la population active
ensuite à partir de 1789 c'est la
bourgeoisie qui ceux qui ceux qui se
lèvent et qui dit nous sommes le peuple
et ensuite c'est ce sont les ouvriers à
partir du 20e siècle qui vont incarner
le peuple et ils sont qu'une bonne
partie de la population active est aussi
en mai 68 il ya une chose de très
nouveau c'est les étudiants et c'est la
jeunesse
qui ne s'était jamais révolter comme ça
en tant que classe sociale mais qui tout
à coup apparaît sur le devant alors
qu'il rejoint par les ouvriers ensuite
mais c'est d'abord une révolution de la
jeunesse
et puis en 2005 il ya les banlieues
ça c'est très particulier aussi et à ce
moment là on dit pas c'est le peuple
c'est les banlieues et puis la lettre
tout à coup il ya alors peut-être ce que
vous appelez vous les sans grades
au fond les gilets jaunes ce serait la
première fois qu'il y aurait une
interruption populaire en france des
sans grade et c'est comme ça qu'ils vont
être vues et souvent disqualifié en fait
on va dire dans les médias et vous leur
sens et ce sont des français moyens
ce sont des des émeutiers qui siègent
l'elysée qui s'attaque à une avenue la
plus belle avenue du monde que sont les
chances des listes des îles son
antisémitisme homophobes
ils sont complotistes qui est surtout
ils sont violents oui effectivement le
terme son grade
je l'emploie mais j'en fais pas vrai
j'en fais pas un fétiche parce que je ne
dis pas c'est comme ça qu'il faut
qualifier les jaunes absolument c'est
pas facile
bon il ya eu pas mal aidé enquêtes qui
ont été faits par des sociologues pour
fait du terrain qu'on fait des récits de
recenser un petit peu qu'ils étaient les
gilets jaunes alors on a quand même une
idée du profil mais il est un il est
calme assez variés et il va un effort
aussi en fonction des régions ils
varient en fonction si vous considérez
les gens qui sont mobilisées sur les
bords point haut ce qu'on va retrouver
plus tôt dans la vie fait station enfin
et notamment à paris c'est pas le même
profil sociologique mais c'est pas non
plus même profil politique
nécessairement fin donc voilà c'est pas
facile
moi j'ai pas fait ce travail là donc
j'ai pas trop m'aventurer là dessus
alors oui sur le sur la disqualification
elle est très net bond l'idée de dire
enfin tous les maux rieuse et grecques
restent dangereuses c'est pas nouveau
c'est le 19e siècle c'est gustave le bon
dieu fait de dire un peuple est
dangereux il ne peut plus gouverner
parler de passion irrépressible les
pales ressentiment enfin un groupe à
part parce que les êtres humains fait de
pires un on retrouve ça dans certaines
déclarations ça c'est pas tout à fait
nouveau alors peut-être que voyez une
forme qui m'a peut-être une forme de
ceux de metric classe qui m'intéressait
que j'ai un peu développé j'ai repris un
concept qui a été développé par un autre
sociologue c'est connu que celui là pour
le coup qui permet à l'oeil et qui parle
alors dans un tout autre contexte
lui c'est un livre sur la liste
l'alphabétisation lui parle
d'ethnocentrisme les traits alors
l'ethnocentrisme
on sait ce que c'est l ethnocentrisme
c'est le fait de prendre pour référence
les valeurs et pratiques de son propre
groupe social de sa propre société et de
sa propre classe et de juger le
disqualifier les autres par tout ce
qu'ils ne sont pas tous cas parler car
il sépare de ce qu'on est
et alors l'ethnocentrisme de l'été les
traits comme la pays comme le
il explique la ire c'est une forme
d'ethnocentrisme mais qui est cette
particularité de de prendre
particulièrement en considération la
maîtrise de la langue et le niveau de
diplôme coiffe assez souvent liés l'un à
l'autre et ça il a semblé que c'était
vraiment une inclinaison très marqué
dans beaucoup de discours médiatique de
personnalités qu'ils aient accès à la
parole publique cet été disqualifié
gilet jaune en entend des gens par
définition de ces pubs incapable il
n'était à penser d'ailleurs qui maîtrise
les codes orthographique
alors comment est ce qu'on ferait
confiance à ces joueurs là on va quand
même pas donné les rênes de la société à
des gens incultes qui en plus que
mauvais les regarder comme il s'habille
d'ailleurs logique jaune à la base c'est
quelque chose qui symbolise t on plutôt
le monde ouvrier
il est tout ce mépris de classe très
fluide avec des coups à un aspect très
culturelle qui est servi à disqualifier
le mouvement et qui pose quand même des
questions absolument fondamental sur
l'imaginaire politique qu'ont ces gens
sont cons ces gens je veux ton palais
j'ai les jambes mais des gens qui
disqualifie il est négligé les jaunes et
crions pas qui décrédibilisent ils
disqualifient parlons pour ces raisons
là on peut être tout à fait critique
envers le mouvement des jeunes l'ont
fait pas l'apologie nécessairement
menacées par moreau en fait je fais là
pour ça mais cette disqualification par
le mépris de classe et en particulier
par les deux centrisme électrique elle
pose des questions sur l'image qu'on
serait de wii 2 de ce que c'est une
démocratie on en revient plutôt un
imaginaire qui suit de deux suffrages
capacitaire quoi il ya ça dans ce sport
m'a jeté sur lui mais dans une autre
tribune de luc ferry qui dit bon bain de
willow peuple sait très bien ce qu'il
élit ses représentants c'est bien par
revenir à l'ancien régime non plus un
mais bon faut pas pousser non plus on va
pas les laisser gouverner et d'ailleurs
feridhi un moment d'ailleurs les braves
gens
sans connaissent leurs limites donc gros
pour eux mais n'ont pas envie de
gouverner qui ont pas s'emmerder avec ça
c'est pas leur domaine
je veux dire qu'il est servi aux autres
donc on voit bien que l'imaginaire qui
est là dedans c'est un imaginaire en
fait aristocratique ou samson littéral
du terme c'est à dire le gouvernement
des meilleurs des élites et alors
baignant c'est à dire oui bon le peuple
a son mot à dire
électoralement par exemple mais voilà
ces gens là ne sont pas apportées je
crois outre mesure par le fait que vous
n'avez pas de personnes issues du monde
ouvrier ou de petits employés en fait du
monde et gilet jaune pour relier
rapidement il dans l'ensemble à
l'assemblée nationale hélas les espèces
de pouvoir en général c'est pas de jeu
je n'entends pas énormément de deux
discours à ce sujet dans les grands
médias
c'est rare ça arrive mais ça lui sert où
on fait une pause on se retrouve juste
après et on continue de d'explorer la
couverture médiatique du traitement des
filets jaunes entre 2018 et 2019
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours avec jean-louis
fille rookie public ils se servent de
leurs armes sur le traitement médiatique
des gilet jaune c'est paru aux éditions
du croquant
votre livre est très intéressant parce
que je suis persuadé que tous ceux que
vous citez dans ce livre puisque je le
rappelle vous avez fait vraiment une
étude très très détaillée de tout ce qui
a pu dire dans dans les médias dans les
grands médias sur au moment du mouvement
des filets jaunes je suis sûr que la
plupart des gens ne se reconnaissent pas
ne se reconnaîtrait pas si vous lisez
j'ai l'impression qu'à ce moment là on
vit dans une espèce de bulle
on est en train de commenter un
événement à chaud c'est souvent le cas
sur les chaînes d'information continue
et au fond je ne suis pas persuadé qu'on
se rende bien compte de ce que l'on dit
notamment sur la violence c'est très
intéressant parce qu'il ya à partir d'un
moment un mot d'ordre ou enfin mot
d'ordre non parce que tout le monde le
dit mais je pense pas que personne
on a donné l'ordre mais que la violence
ne peut s'expliquer car si on explique
on laisse justifient ou plutôt si on
explique on commence à la comprendre et
si on la comprend la justifie donc à
partir de ce moment là il est il devient
absolument impossible sur les plateaux
de télévision de dire attendez soit
cette violence physique répond à une
violence symbolique
certains vont tenter de le dire mais ne
sont pas entendues soit certains vont
dire tout simplement va écouter il ya
des violences policières
il ya des violences des manifestants qui
se répondent c'est à tout ça est
impossible vous montrez bien ceux qui
s'aventurent à le dire on les regarde
comme des dingues comme des dingues
or toute notre histoire toute notre
culture cinématographique absolument
tout nous dit qu'il ya eu des moments
dans l'histoire où il a fallu être
violent et et le cinéma est une histoire
de justification de la violence depuis
le western jusqu'à jusqu'à certains
films policiers
mais neil hannon tout à coup c'est comme
si la violence avait commencé hier
oui c'est vrai de nouveau il ya deux
aspects dans votre question est le
premier il intéresse beaucoup et je suis
pas sûr que j'ai la réponse en fait
en fait ces questions que me pose aussi
vous me dites les gens des médias se
reconnaîtraient pas ben je ne sais pas
c'est une vraie question
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya un effet
d'accumulation de dans l'île et beaucoup
de citations un fléchage effectivement
je le cite énormément de d'extrait
médiatique et donc effectivement se sait
peut-être en compilant ce genre de
choses arrive en compilant en examen en
analysant met en commun tous qu'on
montre un petit peu en tout cas j'espère
qu'elle et l'imaginaire politiques qu'il
ya derrière en fait une matrice commune
alors mais il met une matrice qui est
pas présente de la même manière chez
chacun est peut-être qu'effectivement x
qui est cité dans l'île ne se
reconnaîtrait pas dans les propos d' y
je tiens je veux pas amalgamer tout le
monde en fait ce que je dis simplement
c'est finalement quand on regarde à quel
point ces discours sont fréquents et se
différencie un petit peu les uns des
autres et on se rend compte
qu'effectivement il ya quand même un
imaginaire politique qui circulent et
qui est qui est largement naturalisé en
fin de compte un drame en compte mais
donc ce serait intéressant moi je serais
intéressé de savoir ce que les gens
cités peut-être qu'il serait un peu
heurtée par certains passages mais est
ce que est ce qu'ils se reconnaîtrait
aux pages aux états et sur la violence
alors oui enfin et en particulier sur le
l'interdiction d'expliquer le comprendre
alors c'est sarko qui rend fous les
sociologues mais il ya eu aussi un
discours qu'on entend beaucoup en france
un type en belgique quand même mais
n'est gênant si ça n'avait pas disputé
c'est un grand mot mais s'ils savaient
pas pris des proportions actuelles et
les propos de votre ancien premier
ministre manuel valls qui à un moment
alors j'ai situe exactement quel était
le contexte mais dictée soir c'était sur
le terrorisme est le terrorisme qui
venait
deux citoyens français s'étaient donnés
des terroristes et et après avoir dit
manuel valls après avoir dit qu'il
fallait bien reconnaître qu'il y avait
une sorte d'apartheid en france il avait
dit au fond un peu l' inverse c'est à
dire qu'il ne fallait pas commencer à
essayer de le comprendre
en tout cas d' expliquer parce que si on
explique si on commence à expliquer on
commence à comprendre et si on commence
à comprendre on commence à le justifier
c'était un peu le raisonnement je le
cite de mémoire et mais c'est quelque
chose qu'on fait assez souvent vous avez
raison en france sur certains sujets
mais il ya un exemple qui me dans votre
livre qui est très frappant c'est c'est
le philosophe vincent cespedes qui est
dans une émission je ne sais plus qui
l'animent et il commence à dire ou à
essayer de dire je comprends la violence
et l'animatrice lui dit comment mais
comme si personne n'avait jamais vu dans
l'histoire du monde comprendre la
moindre forme de violence et et vous
montrez bien qu'au fond elle même se
pose la question de savoir si elle peut
laisser dire à quelqu'un sur son plateau
qu'il comprend la violence c'est pas
tant juridiquement que ça pose un
problème parce qu'il faut savoir que les
animateurs de télévision dans un débat
en direct
ils sont soumis eux aussi à la loi il
faut qu'il fasse attention à ce qu'il se
dit sur leur plateau même dans un dans
un débat en direct mais aussi elle
comprend elle se demande comment ça va
être perçue parce qu'aujourd'hui les
animateurs ils sont pas seulement
surveiller juridiquement ils sont pas
seulement sont surveillés par les gens
qui les regardent et qui peuvent
s'indigner de ce qu'ils ont laissé dire
sur le plateau et il ya certainement une
part de ça au fond on a peur un moment
que les gens puissent s'indigner que
quelqu'un et justifier la violence dans
leur émission de télévision oui on peut
commencer par lire que c'est la violence
des manifestants dont il s'agit bien
parce que quand il s'agit de comprendre
la vigilance des policiers les mêmes en
l'occurrence et de la même animatrice
dans une autre émission que je cite
quant à l'or s'est apprécié à lui de ski
je pense qu'il dit qui parle un moment
de l'intervention policière musclée est
alors directement l'animatrice à dire
oui m'enfin il faut comprendre les
policiers sont fatigués qu'ils eux mêmes
ont peur et c'est ce qui est tout à fait
exact en fait de fait que je pense qu'on
peut dans ce sens là
enfin essayer de comprendre ainsi
d'expliquer la violence policière avec
c'est absolument nécessaire mais qu'il
est absolument nécessaire de comprendre
et d'expliquer aussi la violence des
manifestants en fait le parti pris enfin
bon quand on fait des sciences sociales
comprendre a expliqué c'est le service
et le pead quoi c'est à dire qu'on fait
il faut tout essayer de comprendre et
d'expliquer et cette espèce de de signe
d'égalité qu'on met aujourd'hui dans
certains discours qui consisterait à
dire ah oui mais comprendre ou expliquer
peu importe ici la différence entre les
deux termes la distinction
ça revient à justifier ça revient à
justifier moralement mais c'est quelque
chose d'absolument terrible même
intellectuellement et politiquement
en fait si on veut comprendre expliquer
ce n'est pas l'interdiction de de juger
mais c'est simplement une manière de se
mettre dans des conditions pour juger
les dents de manière pertinente
en fait si vous voulez avoir un jugement
adéquat il faut commencer par comprendre
expliqué alors c'est sûr que ce prix bas
ce qui m'avait saisi aussi comme vous
alors je mets en parallèle ce débat là
avec un autre un autre débat cette
fois-ci qu'animé pas pascal praud où là
il ya de la censure enfin pascal broulis
c'est insupportable il coupe la le
propos de son invité elie qui porte
avant du passage sur le plateau alors
passe quelque chose d'assez insignifiant
un nouveau qu'il dit mais dans le cadre
du débat sans cesse pds mais ce qui m'a
frappé c'est que d'abord pour ce que je
connais de lui je ne le connais pas
personnellement vincent cespedes n'a pas
l'air d'être un penseur qu'un vieillard
qui fait partie de sa dette très
radicale ou de très contestataire enfin
c'est quelqu'un qui on voit souvent sur
les plateaux télévisés et du coup je
pense que ça renforce encore le
sentiment de sidération fait du plateau
en fait c'est pas tant qu'ils sont monde
s'attend qui sont heurtées et c'est pas
tant que mais ils ne comprennent pas ce
qui s'est passé à c'est comme si le type
avait dit un truc mais qu'il n'avait
aucun sens et là effectivement on voit
quel est le périmètre
enfin ce que j'appelle un peu à la suite
de bourdieu la doxa dans le disent mais
quel est le périmètre de ce qui est
légitime de 10 ans fin de ce kit de
l'idée déjà reçu et alors al'inverse de
quelque chose qui va à l'encontre des
idées reçues et qui condamnait la
croissance espérée il dit pas je
comprends en france deux justices
passeur il passe son temps à dire je ne
justifie pas il dit simplement je pense
qu'il faut essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ces gens sont là pourquoi c'est
un moment là la confrontation violente
s'impose dans des situations de nas
d'extrême d'extrême précarité aussi et
c'est franchement un vilain l'abbé
députés françois ruffin journalistes et
députés disait c'est tout simple mais je
pense que c'est très juste c'est cette
fois ils acceptaient des gens qui joue
l'essentiel les gilets jaunes
je pense que c'est très juste le fait de
dire à ces gens qui jouent essentiel
avocat manquons vous l'essentiel ça se
radicalise par définition les les
comportements et les positions voilà oui
je sais pas quoi vous dire d'autre si ce
n'est que pour moi ça reste enfin je ne
cesse d surpris qu'on continue à mettre
à considérer que essayer de comprendre
s'est justifié moralement et je ne vois
pas encore une fois comment est ce qu'on
peut faire pour juger quelque chose
c'est qu'elle mérite de dire que le
meilleur moyen jugé c'est dans
l'ignorance
c'est ça c'est quand même un recul
extraordinaire mais il ya aussi moi
est-ce qu'il peut être moi qui me
je suis plus sensible c'est le fait que
quand il ya une abolition de tout le
passé c'est à ça que et j'ai eu cette
impression dans au moment d'aider gilet
jaune et en lisant votre livre sur le
traitement médiatique c'est à dire que
tous les gens signaient s'exprime non
plus aucune référence à tout ce qu'ils
ont pu par ailleurs et avant cela
encensé du type mai 68 par exemple mai
68 on peut pas dire que ça n'est pas
violent on ne peut pas dire qu'il n'ya
pas de destruction ne peut pas dire que
tout ça et pourtant c'est considéré
comme un très grand moment libératoire
extraordinaire etc etc et que et que
tout à coup les mêmes exactions les
mêmes violences et même sont considérés
comme épouvantable et est mille fois
plus condamnable et c'est pourquoi est
ce qu'à un moment on a on peut être
d'accord avec les revendications de mai
68 et ne pas être d'accord avec les
revendications des filets jaunes je suis
comme vous c'est pas la question mais
simplement de vouloir en hand et
discréditer totalement les instruments
ou les moyens alors que ces mêmes
instruments ces mêmes moyens étaient eux
était idolâtré dans une autre période me
paraît incroyable et c'est exactement ce
qu'il s'est passé
ouais alors la question qu'on pourrait
se poser c'est est-ce que mai 68 a pas
un statut un peu particulier afin de
varier beaucoup d'anciens soixante
huitards qui ont retourné leur veste et
qui ont des trajectoires
quand même qu'ils sont plutôt devenus
des gens plutôt autoritaire aujourd'hui
enfin vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de lift
qualité etc rien sur la trajectoire de
certains soixante huitard mais janot 26
mai 68 a pas quand même un statut un peu
à part en tout cas dans l'imaginaire il
en est resté essentiellement celui d'une
prime centre d'une révolte étudiante
culturel d'émancipation par rapport à
des jeunes par rapport aux adultes et
c'est ce qu'on a beaucoup retenu mai 68
n'est pas que ça mais c'est ce qu'on a
beaucoup retenu
si vous prenez d'autres mouvements de
contestation j'ai pas mal là on en parle
beaucoup pour le mans bruxelles et les
150 ans mais la commune de paris par
exemple moi je suis pas sûr que les gens
qui sont qui critique autant la violence
des gilets jaunes soit des grands
admirateurs de la commune de paris donc
c'est une question qui se pose comme le
dit oui finalement il brûle aujourd'hui
ce qu'ils ont adoré hier barret c'est
quand même à se poser la question est ce
que c'est vraiment ce qu'ils ont adoré
hier je suis pas très sûr et d'après ce
qui est sûr aussi c'est que l'âge de
l'enfant elle est enfin je viens encore
quand vous voyez
je ne fait nulle part à toulouse il ya
bien entendu une fois que c'est assez
clair mais il y aussi des réactions de
peur des froids c'est des images
spectaculaires voit les images en plus
elles ont tourné en boucle dans les
télévisions
voilà je pense qu'il y en ait plus très
habitué aussi il ya beaucoup de violence
qui s'exerce dans la société qui sont
des violences médiatisés en fait c'est
un peu l'exemple que je vous donnais
avec les 2 points de pib
ouais c'est des violences qui je viens
si vraiment on avait conscience de la
violence de ce que c'est de produire des
chaussures 18 heures par jour dans un
salaire de misère dans des petits
entrepôts je suis pas sûr qu'on les
porterait encore moi y compris
d'ailleurs je suis le premier dans le
cas donc ce sont des formes de violence
quand même qu'on sait pas quand il n'est
pas au courant mais on ne perçoit pas
viscéralement perçoit on les perçoit pas
vraiment dans leur matérialité quoi ici
c'est des violences qui font du bruit
qui sont proches d'abord c'est ça aussi
qui s'est passé quand vous vous mariez
des banlieues les révoltés par la voix
de banquier il a gagné quelque chose de
très intéressant c'est qu'il se passe en
banlieue c'est pas seulement kanak s'est
laissé passer leur chance et les galets
quartier qui les gens des quartiers qui
de la faune celui de la faune dans les
quartiers ce qui brûle entre guillemets
c'est chez eux c'est pas dans les beaux
quartiers de paris
ici il ya quand même quelque chose que
j'essaie d'évoquer aussi en parallèle à
celle de durand rapports entre profane
et sacré on n'a pas un seul monde
extérieur ce monde de plus que dans les
yeux d'un certain nombre de
commentateurs qui débarque déjà on leur
a même demandé en plus de façon violente
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on voit dans les
médias tout le temps et dans des rues
des quartiers qui généralement ne voit
ça qu'à la télévision
ce genre de violences est un ménage
enfin j'ai pas faire de procès
d'intention mais pour certains ont une
image peut-être un peu dé réaliser de ce
que c'est l'aspect terrifiant je prends
pas ce mois pour faire du bateau ce bel
aspect terrifiant de la vie de beaucoup
de gens de classes populaires
aujourd'hui en 2021
et qu'est ce que c'est que les violences
ne pas pouvoir se payer à boucher se
chauffer acheter un cadeau à noël pour
ses glaces etc
on le voyait aussi à tous les reportages
qui se scandalisaient du fait que les
gens ne puissent pas consommé pendant
les fêtes sans jamais mettre ça en lien
avec le fait que si les jaunes étaient
dans la rue précisément c'est parce
qu'ils pouvaient pas consommer mais même
pas fonctionné le superflu mais pour
certains consommer l'essentiel est pas
parce que les bac s a été fermé à cause
des manifestations mais parce que
simplement il ya des tas de quoi donc il
ya une des réalisations aussi de de
beaucoup de formes de violence donc
défendu violences sont très visibles
très spectaculaire et qui me font peur
et d'autres qui pas qu'ils sont passés
sous silence ne paraissent pas
nécessairement comme tel quoi il ya
certainement il vous assistez aussi là
dessus parce que c'est constamment dans
l'est la rhétorique de la couverture
médiatique du mouvement
c'est le fait que ça se passe dans les
beaux quartiers au fond dans les
quartiers vitrine mais le pari est de la
france que ce soit les champs-elysées
les ministères le quartier de l'elysée
et on revient en permanence sur le fait
que c'est dans ce quartier là que ça se
passe
et forcément ça fait plus peur et vous
me citiez la commune aux forces qu'on va
reprocher aux communards et qu'on peut
leur reprocher encore aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs c'est à la fois les
fusillades bien sûr mais aussi d'avoir
incendié paris d'avoir mis le feu à
paris alors là c'est pas au point de la
commune parce que des années après la
commune il ya encore du tourisme à paris
pour venir voir les ruines là ça n'est
pas le cas mais mais mais néanmoins
c'est vrai que ça fait peur à ce moment
là on a l'impression qu'on s'attaque à
ce qu'il ya de plus beau dans paris et à
paris alors je dis parce que là pour le
coup c'est peut-être bon en tant que
belge francophone 3 la france est très
proche
j'ai grandi en voyant les mêlées la
télévision française en lisant les
journaux français en regardant monde de
la musique française annoncée c'est un
univers très exotique pour moi mais
malgré tout je suis pas français il ya
quand même quelque chose de
spectaculaire en français la chaussée
entre paris et paris et la province quoi
on n'a pas ça en belgique il est à
bruxelles et le reste de la belgique
c'est pas aussi net en tout cas en
france et kamil sacralisation paris et
alors je n'ai pas fait de jeu c'est plus
une intuition à c'est une observation
qui est plus lors de l' intuition il m'a
semblé qu'on parlait même infiniment
plus des manifestations des violences et
des dégâts qui ont été causés à paris
que de ce qui se passait à bordeaux à
toulouse valium en france a donc
effectivement il ya oui clairement de sa
wii et et puis au fond pendant tout ce
traitement médiatique des déjeuners
jaune enfin au centre de tout ce
traitement médiatique des gels et jaune
vous montrez bien qu'il ya la question
de la vérité c'est ça revient en
permanence un à la fois la vérité du
mouvement social est-ce qu'il ya est ce
que c'est vrai tout ce que vous venez de
dire qu'il ya des gens qui sont qui ont
du mal à se nourrir en france
aujourd'hui enfin en l'occurrence en
2018 et en 2019
voilà cette question là c'était on en
cherchait la vérité mais la vérité du
mouvement social la vérité des violences
policières qui était souvent vous
l'avais dit dans les grands médias
négliger la vérité du peuple est ce que
c'est bien le peuple la vérité de la
démocratie c'est quoi la démocratie la
démocratie c'est dans les urnes c'est
pas dans la rue c'était donc la question
du vérité la vérité elle est revenue en
permanence oui elle est sacrément
compliqué je t'apprécie d'abord décider
en deux minutes
je demande un peu dans le dernier
chapitre du livre effectivement parce
que je pense que c'est un enjeu central
et moi ça me paraissait aussi important
parce que
mais j'étais conscient en écrivant ce
livre que j'avais une posture facile
c'est à dire quand vous vous faites la
critique du discours des autres vous
êtes un peu comme dans la position hors
sol avec dans la position de ce nous
invite en position de ceux qui donnent
des leçons
même si vous n'avez pas envie de le
faire et j'en étais conscient et je
voulais pas je voulais éviter ça autant
que je pouvais et donc essayer aussi de
deux d'essayer de critiquer ma propre
position coiffe un minimalement en tout
cas lui donner quelques voilà quelques
pistes et donc à la fin du livre
effectivement je pose cette question de
la vérité alors qui peut s'entendre à la
fois comme la vérité du discours
médiatique est ce que ce que disent les
médias brel mais aussi la qualité du
discours sociologique ce que moi je dis
sur les médias est ce que c'est vrai m
mon projet de vous croire et
certainement pas sur parole je l'espère
et donc ça pose des questions alors moi
ce qui m'a fallu fils que j'ai essayé de
prendre je vais l'aborder par ce fils là
c'est le fait que alors je veux pas
tomber dans une sorte de relativisme en
france il ya des faits il ya des
distorsions des faits et je veux dire
s'il ya 5000 manifestants et qu'il y en
a pas omis il l'a dit enfin voilà il y
avait fait un ya des faits vérifiables
foughali vérifiables assidûment il ya
les vérités objectives mais après la
connaissance qu'on est assez vérité
objective elle est souvent l en but
alors j'ai peut-être vous donner un
exemple ce sera vous pourrez rencontrer
montrer pour moi où l enjeu
justement on prend l'exemple d'une
manifestation si il ya une manifestation
de gilet jaune et vous avez je sais par
la police qui dit il et 5000
manifestants et des gilets jaunes qui
disent pas du tout il y en avait 100
milles bon mettons sa série dans fictif
un peu importe les chiffres 1 c'est
juste pour l'exemple
et puis on ferme et on vous fait une
enquête rigoureuse vous avez les moyens
voilà vraiment une enquête statistique
extrêmement précise et vous arrivez à
les terminer fait long feu y en avait
sept îles admettons vous pouvez dire ok
j'en avais pas 100 milles
c'était fou et en quelle année sans bill
est donc dès que généralement ça va
faire d'ailleurs les gros titres mais
fabriqué et cuit tout ça c'était faux
n'y avait pas cent mille manifestants et
d'aller 7000 bon c'est bien c'est utile
de le faire mais après qu'une fois vous
avez dit ça c'est là que les problèmes
commencent en fait c'est que vous avez
fait le vph est la base la base actuelle
nécessaire mais après elles vont passer
toutes les questions qui vont pas être
réductible un enjeu de vérité contre le
mensonge mais qui vont être lié à des
partis pris interprétatif et à des
partis pris politiques dont par exemple
ok il y avait six mille cinq cents
manifestants mais on dit quoi sur ces
manifestants non on les appelle comment
ces manifestants est-ce que les
america's heures ou est ce qu'on les
appelle manifestants pro démocratie
comme par exemple ce n'est un comme
c'est pas vrai de dire casseurs ou sepa
ferait le lien manifestants pro
démocratie c'est pas faux non plus
c'est un parti pris c'est une lecture
mais par contre vous n'allez pas du tout
montré la même image enfin vous donné la
même image d'eux mêmes représentations
de ces manifestants selon des labbes les
casseurs ou ou manifestants pro
démocratie
ils disent allez faire quoi vous allez
faire un reportage immergé au milieu des
bataillons de crs
et puis vous allez interroger la famille
des crs qui avaient expliqué qu'ils ont
peur qu'ils vivent vraiment et puis qui
sont utilisés etc
ce qui est tout à fait vrai ce sera
peut-être reportages de qualité d'où
sera peut-être vrai où vous allez faire
un reportage eux qui va suivre des gilet
jaune et qui va montrer comme silver
celles ci sont désespérés et qui sera
peut-être tout à fait vrai aussi et il
le fait de faire l'un ou l'autre
et puis de le faire de telle manière et
pas de telle autre eh bien ça parti-pris
interprétatif ça s'appelle une ligne
éditoriale et oui j'ai pas de problème
parce que les médias et des limites à
une ligne éditoriale ça très bien qu'un
média est une ligne éditoriale
la seule chose plutôt il ya deux choses
je pense qu'il serait nécessaire
la première chose c'est d'assumer la
ligne éditoriale comme une ligne
éditoriale n'est pas de faire comme s'il
est évident comme si ça allait de soi
qu'il faille traiter des choses comme ça
c'est un parti pris on l'assument
et puis la deuxième c'est qu'il ya un
peu de pluralisme ses équipes à la même
ligne éditoriale partout ne pas
caricaturer les choses mais il ya quand
même
eu une ligne éditoriale qui est très
dominantes et les autres qui passe
plutôt par des niches ou bien par des
petits moments où on pourra y compris
dans les chaînes mais même dans les
chaînes de télévision continue
d'informations continues on a vu des
moments plus favorable au gie des
journaux energa la télévision des débats
houleux gilet jaune était invité sur le
plateau on leur posait des questions
d'analystes
on leur demandait d'analyser leur
situation et c'était des moments
finalement assez rare parce que
d'habitude ces jours là soit ils sont
pas à la télévision
soit on les interroge debout sur leur
lieu de travail ou un point parmi le
public
ils peuvent lever le bras pour poser une
vague questions ou donna un témoignage
toujours fatale à rien ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure il voit dans l'affect
donc ils vont donner un témoignage on va
leur demander d'analyser leur situation
il ya eu quelques moments de bison ou un
peu plus pluraliste où il y avait aussi
ça qui s'est passé mais voilà il ya
comme un parti-pris interprétatif qui
est dominant qui ce qui paraît jmar une
question vérité compte mensonge et je
pense que vraiment ils gagneraient fin
tout le monde les sociologues je faisais
vraiment livré j'assume des
réintroductions
les choix interprétatifs qui sont les
miens notamment le fait de m'intéresser
principalement justement discours de
délégitimation du mouvement j'aurais pu
faire un autre livre ainsi un choix quoi
il faut l'assumer il ya une part de
subjectivité maintenant même si après on
essaie d'être rigoureux et ses amis une
part de subjectivité jeux premium est ce
que vous n'avez pas l'impression que
l'unanimisme dont vous parlez qui est
indéniable quand on lit votre livre on
voit bien qu'il ya un unanimisme moment
là est-ce qu'il n'est pas aussi on va
dire le le contrecoup de l'apparition d'
énormément de points de vue
du fait que avec internet tout le monde
est devenu émetteurs et qu'au fond les
journalistes les commentateurs n'ont
plus le monopole du commentaire d'un
événement sur les sur la révolution
française il nous reste ce que pensait
robespierre mara et danton sur napoléon
c'est ce que nous a dit napoléon fonds
n'a pas le témoignage des grognards ou
qu'il est très rare on le prend pas de
la même manière
mai 68 même vous avez tant sortant les
leaders qui s'expriment sur europe 1
mais pas sur la radio d'état ni sur la
télévision d'état non plus et c'est
europe 1 où les journaux c'est tout mais
on entend pas on n'a pas là le film de
la manifestation vue du point de vue du
manifestant comme on l'a maintenant
pendant les vielles les jo foley chez
les jaunes ont eu la parole sur les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook partout et
on a l'impression que les sur les grands
médias au fond c c'est le voeu c'est
devenu la houle et le pouvoir
intellectuel journalistique ou politique
répond à à ce qui est dit partout
ailleurs non je partage et c'est votre
analyse je préférais commenter mais j'ai
pas là je partage vraiment l'essentiel
et je pense qu'il ya enfin je me demande
si c'est pas d'ailleurs eu un peu de
panique dans l'est les médias classiques
de voir justement émerger un certain
nombre de médias alternatifs qui donc
ont peur ils icher qui sont pas toujours
des niches
quand on commence à faire trois cent
mille quatre cent mille 500 millions
avec des formats la d1 plus proche du
vôtre
c'est à dire donner la parole à
quelqu'un pendant une heure puisqu'on
est en train de faire là il faut le dire
c'est impossible sur france 2 ou sur tf1
ou pouvaient donner la parole pendant
une heure à quelqu'un qui est pas très
connu il faut le dire en plus qui est
belge et qui a écrit un bouquin
pratiques sur les gilets jaunes en se
disant ça vaut la peine d'en parler
pendant une heure mais c'est
inimaginable en fait sur la plupart des
médias traditionnels
et pourtant ce que montre un certain
nombre de médias alternatifs c'est que
non seulement il ya moyen de le faire
mais le gros plus ça marche relativement
équipe que je ne suis pas ici pour
certains médias
je vais en oublier mais je démens les on
les connaît tous et l'ina vous vraiment
un invité va avoir deux heures deux
heures et demie pour s'exprimer et il va
y avoir 300 400 me de vue donc c'est
quelque chose qui est presque un an un
modèle alternatif et je crois
qu'effectivement il doit y avoir une
accréditation dans les grands médias
d'autant qu'on sait quand même qu'il ya
encore une fois vous connaissez mieux
que moi je commence à vraiment de
l'extérieur mais il ya une fragilité
économique aujourd'hui qui est qui est
très grande
notamment dans la presse avec le
vieillissement du lutteur de lectorat
avec le numérique la gratuité et c'est
donc effectivement mais il ya un
décalage ce dont on disait dont on
parlait tout à l'heure avec eux les
images des violences des yeux des
débordements des mains arrachées et
c'est qu'ils circulaient dont un peu
partout sauf dans les médias est assez
révélatrice de sa main effectivement les
médias n'ont plus le monopole de ce
genre d'information est alors qu'en bas
quand ça se voit partout sauve la photo
n'est ça fait pas beaucoup pour leur
réputation quoi et de l'hostilité de
beaucoup de gilet jaune envers les
médias qui a parfois pris des formes
assez agressif quand on peut en discuter
et n'était pas forcément souhaitable
mais je pense qu'aussi et là aussi on
était de comprendre d'où il vient
quand vous il ya combien alors j'ai pu
les chiffres en tête et des milliers de
tirs de l bd de grenade dans les
manifestations exigeant tendance vous ne
m'entendez pas parler pendant un an et
demi sur bfm tv sur ces news sur tf1 que
sais-je
bon voilà il ya les fatalement un peu de
gym jean de d'énervement merci jean
louis xi ruda va passer toute cette
émission avec nous qu'ils se servent de
leurs armes
c'est sous titré le traitement
médiatique des gilet jaune c'est paru
aux éditions du croquant
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]